this sounds like one of those things
we're just like he's totally like he's
making this off to make himself look
good if you ask my parents
and where i wanted to work when i was
seven eight years old it was microsoft
[Music]
hello all and welcome to mooco's corner
it's a show about leading a life that
feels more you in your life and tech
career i'm your host miyuko inoue and
invita come on in sit down get cozy
maybe grab a cup of tea and enjoy the
show today on the show we have den de
lamarski
den is an engineer working on helping
scale the developer relations
organization as a principal program
manager at microsoft he's the host of
the work item podcast where he sits down
with folks from a range of industries
roles and backgrounds to learn about
their career journeys lessons learned
and what it takes to map your very own
track
so
how are you doing let's just start there
it's been good uh it's been good because
i just recently had last week just kind
of a short break from my work so i had a
little bit of a week of a time off of
not worrying about meetings and emails
and now i'm back to the corporate grind
which is
uh
you know
it's the same as always because i'm
talking to somebody that worked in
netflix and i'm sure it was exactly the
same way yo yes i even have my netflix
bottle too
i am on brand too with content and
learning yeah i
if there is
like i don't know like every time they
say congratulations we went through a
rework here or something like another
bottle really like
how many shirts bottles stickers like i
literally have a box of stickers in my
closet and all the t-shirts that i've
ever gotten are just like in a box
because i'm just like i don't know what
to do with this like can i donate it
because that would be weird if someone
random was like wearing a shirt from my
team my wife was making fun of me
because she said literally like we will
never have to buy t-shirts ever
and i and but then again personal
preference
this again just me but i told you it was
like please do not give me branded
t-shirts i hate them
like i wear uniqlo and this is this is
my jam
this is unicorn uniqlo wow we're
matching yeah it is yeah because it's
like it's the most plain
basic but it's looking good it's like
just give me uniqlo this is it
yeah i agree if every tech team could
just give me a plain white tee instead
of whatever branded stuff they give me
i would have been so happy like that
would have been my whole wardrobe but i
would have been okay with that
i will spray paint your logo if you want
me to but just give me a white tee
that's exactly my mentality on it yes
yeah 100
yeah yeah yeah for sure
well i'm glad you got a week off that
sounds like it was a it was a good time
did you just stay like staycation
yes yes it's definitely a staycation
because uh well i guess we're kind of
getting out of the pandemic which is
kind of odd to say and it's so weird now
to see people in real life and
are making like barbecue plans and i'm
like are we allowed to on instagram
stories people are going to bars and i'm
like what are bars right
concerts same way like you can go to a
stand-up comedy show now yes apparently
yeah
like it's i don't know it feels very
weird to go back to
normal
normal
how do you yeah how do you feel about
like are you like ready to embrace it
are you kind of just like no
i don't want to i'll i'll put it this
way it has it's it has its benefits and
it has its drawbacks right so like from
the benefit side i think i'm ready to go
back to normal i have not seen my
friends since 2019.
like no joke uh the last time i've met
some of the people here in vancouver
where i am
was
2019
wow it's crazy that's a long time right
so it's like it's it's exciting to
actually like
meet and say you know hey like let's
have a barbecue am i going to shake
hands no uh am i going to meet them yeah
that's nice
um so it's nice to actually get the
social connection i feel like everyone
gets a little bit of that cabin fever
we're just like we've been locked in and
just with ourselves
and yeah so it you know but at the same
time i got used to remote work so much
that now when people be like go work in
an office i'm like
no
no
what's an office like i don't want to go
like like my commute is exactly five
minutes
wow right
well like because i get up i shower and
i just i'm at work
i don't have to go wait for the bus get
across the harbor get like
none of those things like that's awesome
because
and i'm and when i'm done i just shut
off my computer i'm done yeah yeah i
don't have to drive anywhere right it's
amazing it's so nice it's like i reflect
on like when i used to commute uh
specifically my commute to patreon was
just like the worst because i would
spend an hour and a half on a train and
i was like how could i do that like
that's so long like i could watch
movies and just like spend so much
quality time on my on myself with my
with people that i like instead of like
on a train right yeah so it's it's like
i don't know
it's interesting though because i feel
like covid has
necessitated a lot of this like we can't
ever go back to this 40-hour work week
we can't ever go back to the office like
there's this entire like work culture
revolution that's happening that i think
is like it's been happening and it's
only been accelerated by kovid but i'm
just like wow people are excited to just
like not
work 40 hours anymore or like not have
to commute and that's kind of nice
because that's what we all wanted in the
first place
right and because for a lot of people i
like to think this a wake-up call is
like you don't actually need to be in an
office to be productive yeah like you
like your location doesn't matter
because before and this is a very kind
of crude way of putting it but it's like
butts and seats right it's like well how
many like you people you have sitting in
an office that's your measure of
productivity and people start realizing
that it actually doesn't matter i can be
just as productive from home
totally i think it's actually
interesting because you know it's like
it's tools right like zoom and slack is
like if you have that you can like
communicate with people very easily very
quickly but i also think it's because
like we're all just so used to
communicating online nowadays where it's
like we don't have to like it's so
efficient you know we're not writing
like like 10 page emails to ask for one
thing anymore we're just like yo do you
have this cool thanks and like that's it
like we've just gotten so good at
communicating that medium so it had to
be now it's just like it's a perfect
storm if you look at it from all
different angles and it's just like so
fascinating
right right i mean there's a lot of
benefits and people just learn to adapt
right like humans are
very adaptable compared to like a lot of
other species because we survived for so
long but at the same time
i i think there's there's still that
component of kind of the social
interaction that you need with people
right like you can't replace
me going into a meeting room and just
using a whiteboard with a zoom call like
no matter how you try it's just not the
same it's not like looking across and
seeing somebody being very disappointed
in my suggestion is way different than
not seeing them on camera and then
they're saying like yeah that's a very
nice idea then thank you right
i'd rather see disappointment face to
face totally yeah there's a vibe that
you pick up on when you're in person
which is so important everybody's about
the vibes
right right right no the personal
connection is important and this is
where but i think we'll adapt we'll
adapt and there's a lot of in corporate
speakers like the hybrid work mode right
right which is
some remote some not remote
how that's gonna work we'll learn
because i don't know alert yeah i will
always adapt about how it'll end up we
don't really know yet this is a new
territory as it always is for the human
species though right so
when it when hasn't it been yeah
exactly right but i feel you my um i
haven't seen my parents since like end
of 2019 oh my goodness and uh cause they
live in japan but my mom's coming this
friday
uh well that's exciting yeah and i'm
like wow i haven't seen my own parents
in almost in like a year and a half
which is like the longest i haven't ever
seen them so for stuff like that right
like hanging out with friends they
haven't seen in a long time
it's a welcome change for sure oh
absolutely i am i'm looking forward to
catching up with friends and family for
sure definitely yeah
well i'm so glad things are going well
things are moving forward okay well i
have a couple of topics but uh i think
we're gonna start off with a question
that a lot of my listeners i think are
probably gonna have because they don't
get the opportunity to talk to someone
from this background very often but dad
what is it like to work from microsoft
oh goodness where do i even start on
that i i think look i also
put this big asterisk and whatever i
said this is my own experience right
like don't take this you know i don't
want to get a call from hr and saying
you did not correctly represe this is my
experience right right so
one of the things that
is good about microsoft and i really
enjoy is the fact that there is options
i started microsoft as an engineer i was
building demo video games when windows 8
was the big hyped up thing right and
we're like a new whole collection of
apps that you can run now they're called
metro apps and you can build games so i
was building that then that was when i
was an intern then i came back as a
program manager because i had no idea
what a program manager did i honestly
had no concept of that job i saw i was
like that sounds fun i'll apply
and i got that job
i worked on outlook desktop and uh you
know if you have a problem with outlook
it's my fault i apologize in advance
and after that i work in developer
relations i
then
quit for a little bit i worked at aws
and then went back to microsoft and i'm
working now as a technical advisor but
the theme that kind of
permeates throughout my entire career is
the availability of those options right
so if you ever get bored of being
somebody in outlook
go do something else within the company
you don't need to actually leave i think
that's one of the
benefits of working for a corporation
that's that big is just because it does
so many things we're like at some point
you're like hey i want to build video
games cool you have xbox there's a bunch
of game studios you can build minecraft
if you want to all these things right
get tired of that oh i like to build you
know cloud internet of things things
well go work for that team that builds
those things right it gets it's very
well i don't want to say easy that's
oversimplifying it's like you still need
to go through the interview process but
if you have that kind of itch of doing
something else you always have those
options
and
by virtue of that
you get those super talented people
that work in all these teams that are
very accessible i was shocked by how
accessible that is until i actually
encountered myself because people were i
was asking one of my mentors it's like
well
i'm curious about this other team and i
wonder how they do things and
tell me more he's like did you reach out
to anyone that team was like well no
because they don't like
reach out to that team
i just reached i emailed them and be
like hey i'm this rando i'm dead
now you don't know me
can i talk to you about what your team
does like sure
well the
guy that invented the kinect alex kipman
that you know the the motion tracking
for the xbox like the just dance and all
those fun things yeah
big fan and i was like i love to connect
i play all those games can i
can i like sit down with the guy that
invented it and i was like in my mind i
was building it i was like oh my god is
this like this local celebrity and it's
like i don't know i emailed him
within like an hour their admin was like
like here's a coffee chat for like two
weeks later like what wow
so
it's cool right it's like that the
access to those people is just
phenomenal and i think that that's what
i love about working microsoft is
because you get to learn from all these
people and you just get constantly
challenged in a good way was like ah i
know nothing actually so
right that's so cool i mean like
microsoft is one of those companies that
like really didn't and doesn't limit
itself to any one industry and so like
the thing that you said about you can
you can stay within microsoft but work
on so many different things could not be
more true at microsoft probably like
working at xbox and aws and like like
whatever i'm sorry i was really
unfamiliar with microsoft stuff these
days but like whatever else you know is
there it's just like that's like its own
silicon valley almost really right in
one company
right right uh absolutely and it's just
just
never get bored because if you do get
bored
you can do something else um
that's cool would you say like in in
like your prolific journey across the
lands of microsoft was the culture of
each place very different and distinct
from the other or did it still feel like
you were working for like one big
company like was there similarities or
was it like really different from one to
another so that's a great question i
think
overarching theme about kind of the
corporate culture is about the same
right there is
not to get into too much of kind of the
corporate speak if you will but there's
kind of the growth mindset right where
it's like everyone it's not about
knowing everything but it's about trying
to learn
everything it's about trying to
understand your customers so that
has been pretty kind of typical across
the board across the entire company any
team you join they will talk about that
and they will actually put that in
action so
again not to sound like somebody that is
just here is like a corporation good but
um it actually it actually works because
people believe in the fact that if we're
going to work together as one
big company as many disjoint teams we
still have we have a common goal right
that's that's the culture but i think
there is going to be nuances across
different teams that are going to be
slightly different right and that's
natural because
your product is different the things
that you build are different the people
that you're building that with are
different
and they have a different approach to
how you structure your engineering
processes how you do data analysis how
you talk to customers all these
processes
are
i i'd say that they have a lot of
variability across teams right so but
but those are not necessarily i don't
want to paint them necessarily as
culture per se more so than just kind of
specifics to the team the overarching
culture is the same though
right right right yeah wow
okay so like hearing all this stuff
about microsoft like makes total sense
about why you work there because i did
some internet stalking sleuthing about
you and your work and everything and
luckily for me you write a lot about
yourself on your blog and like what you
think about stuff which is so
fascinating to read because i was just
like
this is so cool like what you do is so
cool and i love the way that you like
lead life and stuff so i kind of want to
get into that especially because you
were like one of the things i like about
microsoft is that it's never boring and
i i think it's like interesting because
you're from what i can see
like a prolific like side project
masterer like you have so many side
projects you listed on your website
you're like machine learning stats
computer graphics your podcast
photography and video editing like those
are all
very deep disciplines that are highly
technical like it's not like light
reading it's like those are all very
intense fields so have you always been
someone who's like had a lot of side
projects a lot of interests like you
always want to kind of like keep things
fresh sort of person uh
and i'm just gonna living up to the
jackable trades master of none
but
i've always been a curious person if you
talk to my parents back from the early
days growing up in eastern europe like i
grew up in a family that
didn't have a lot so we were
not wealthy by any means so
any opportunity to dig into things that
i have never seen like a computer or a
new gadget was just mind-blowing it was
just like whoa how do i do this
and so it kind of i had that innate
curiosity from very very early on where
i just like i'm curious how this works i
have no idea i've never touched this
thing before but now i do
and so that led to
i think like two two things curiosity
was one and the other thing is get more
done with less
right and this is where i try to get
creative with like how do i do this one
thing with this other thing that are not
supposed to be working together right
and
a lot of that just kind of grew
throughout my entire life i think since
those early days where that curiosity
and the desire to say okay what can i do
with this
and that led me to think about my
my career the things that i do the
things that i build where
i just was you know
oh i have never built a web api
i wonder how that works
let me try and gluing this together and
then i would put it together and then
like ah this is kind of cool
i wonder if i can make this talk to my
like light bulb or something like that
okay now i did it oh hold on a second
but i wonder if i do that
and i connected to my like this other
device and like and that just kind of
snowballed snowballed and a lot of
things and funnily enough my career
started from this kind of tinkering with
totally silly things because at some
point i don't know if folks that are
listening to the show remember the zune
player that might be a little bit too
far in the past
at some point
z-u-n-e
hmm wait that was the microsoft like
response to the ipod i think
it was like a it was like it looked like
an ipod yes it was i okay i vaguely
remember that yes yeah okay so i'm
clearly too old for the show but uh so
there was a zun player and it had kind
of like the version of itunes for
windows which is the zoom desktop client
and i figured out a way to
just like
get movies from that thing without
actually like doing a bunch of you know
things you're supposed to do movies by
virtue of using their own api
and i
at that point i was a naive college
student i was like oh i've got to write
a blog post about it what else would i
do and i just wrote this blog post and
somebody reached out and they're like
hey maybe you should come talk to us uh
and and that kind of bootstrapped my
professional network because i was like
now i'm connected to all these people at
microsoft and that's how i ended up at
microsoft wow
so it was written in the stars like you
were meant to work at microsoft all from
the zune player who knew you know it's
funny because if you ask my parents
and where i wanted to work when i was
seven eight years old it was microsoft i
i don't know i'm not like this sounds
like one of those things where it's just
like he's totally like he's making this
up to make himself look good it's not it
really is not it is it's
yeah like in like the school like what
do you want to be when you grow up like
you were like i would work at microsoft
or something i wanted to be an ecologist
and software engineer
whoa that's a cool combo
the first part of the combo never worked
out but the the second was okay because
yeah you know my my parents were well
they still are they're
economy and computer science professors
so that was kind of
i want to say not in a negative way like
just beating into me like you do this
and uh
i stuck around with it and i love it i
love that my parents are also both
educators and i feel like like when you
have parents who are teachers they teach
you how to like learn stuff or they
teach you hacks or they like to be kind
of naturally curious and like follow
that
so i okay i can see why we get along
just from like our own backgrounds and
stuff we have some commonality there the
the educator parent background i'll tell
you this this is one of exactly as you
said it's learning how to learn and all
these tricks as to how do you memorize
things and how do you understand and how
do you ask and when do you ask the
question why why is this this way why is
this other thing this other way and how
do they work together like that came
from that background it's like don't
take
an answer for what it is right like ask
why keep asking why until people are
just like
shut up den
i'm not answering that anymore right so
like i just yeah that annoying curiosity
has been with me throughout my entire
life
yeah it's you know when you have people
who are raising you who know how others
teach you they know how to like be like
okay like they're teaching my kid this
but this is what they're leaving out so
right let's have my kid go in there and
ask like sometimes a little annoying
though because i was just like my
parents are better students than i am
and they tell me all the things that i'm
not doing well but like it also taught
me to be yeah it also taught me to be
very introspective and like try to think
things from different perspectives yeah
you know you work with what you're dealt
with right you're going right and it's
not a bad hand i'll put it this way like
it's like sure i am so thankful
that
when i was at the age where i was like i
want to do my own thing i was like
here's how you should be thinking about
your own thing and i was like what do
you know i'm seven i know everything
right
i didn't surprise you i know everything
i'm gonna work at microsoft right you
showed them
i just remember my parents like just
pick one just not ecologist or just
which one of those two do you want to do
i want to do both because i'm
sure porque no les dos you know like why
not both exactly it's i was that meme in
real life
look at me now well okay so like for as
someone who's like serial hobbyist
serial curiosity driven person one of
the things that i often think about in
managing that in my own life is like how
do you manage to spend your energy it
seems like you've got a lot of things
like going on and that you're working on
like how do you balance it because in my
life it's just like there's just so much
stuff i want to do all the time but like
time and energy is so limited so like
how do you go about thinking about that
for a lot of the things that are related
to not my primary job right because
primary job is one of those things you
have to do it and you have to be good at
it and get better at it right that's
your responsibility for things like
hobbies i'd say like it ebbs and flows
right and it it's all driven by again
the curiosity what am i curious about
today a couple of months ago i started
watching a youtube channel sam daws arts
with sam yang and he just does digital
drawings i have no idea about digital
drawings i have never done that in my
life i'm
a terrible artist period let alone
digital like i'll make worse just in
pixels
but i watch those videos i was like oh
this is kind of cool what if i started
learning that right and the first thing
i was like
okay i'm going to get a mechanical
pencil a sketchbook and a one of the
cheapest wacom tablets that i can
connect to my computer and i will learn
how to do this i will learn how to draw
and like it's just been kind of an
exploration just purely because
no i'm curious about it i i wonder what
that will lead to i don't know maybe
it's going to lead to nothing
it'll at least be an experience and so
i'm sure some skill because you've
actually done and gone and done the work
but like do you plan about like here's
what i'm gonna be doing every day to get
from a to b because i'm very curious
about the what am i curious about today
like that's so living in the present
moment and that's very opposite me i
think so i just i'm just like i'm
curious about how you think about your
life
so i i'd say
it's it's less so about kind of just
thinking about today because i
definitely do have a
plan right where it's i think about okay
what's the project that i want to
achieve within this week this quarter
this year this is something that i'm
very
very very specific about where i just i
don't do things randomly but because
once i get into a mode of okay i'm
genuinely curious about this
this is a topic i want to explore
i set myself some goals that i drive
towards okay if i'm exploring digital
drawing by the end of the year i want to
launch a website where i will
show what i draw
like it sounds silly right it sounds
very simple it's like okay whatever
right it's like start an instagram
account but it's like but this is my
goal i will get to the point where i'm
comfortable
having a website where i can say okay
this is what i draw i like i learn in
public if you will right and this is
what the goal that i go towards
when i pick up any kind of projects be
it machine learning or like the other
day i reverse engineered a stream deck
so i can make it do whatever i want
because the api that they offer out of
the box was not good enough for me
apparently
i was like okay my goal is to make this
a library that i can share with other
developers i will document it i will
learn how to build libraries and this is
my project
right so i don't do it for the sake of
just i'll just do it and then drop it
and then it's just there
because then then you're getting
randomized with a bunch of other things
every day because you know the interest
shift but this is also a forcing
function where sometimes you get into
the mode where you're just like i just
don't feel like doing it anymore right
yeah yeah but at the same time this is
kind of like you know what i set a goal
i will finish this
and i will see where it goes
because chances are it will not go
anywhere that's entirely possible but i
will
go through it to the end
and see how it works
yeah you're like not afraid of failure
you're probably someone who's like
everything is a net positive like having
gone through it is better than not and
like i know that there's like you're it
seems like you're a very
optimistic person like a glass half full
because i feel like it's hard sometimes
to commit to something be like i might
get nothing out of this like i'll spend
so many hours and like stay up late or
whatever but it's okay if i don't get
anything out of that like have you
always been kind of a pause like how do
you absolutely
get there
again just naturally very positive
person i think you put it best i'm just
not afraid to fail because what's the
worst that can happen right i am very
much cognizant of the fact that ninety
percent of my projects will fail that's
just i mean that's just real life that
that's just how it goes like i'll i have
so many projects on github that if you
go to my profile i'll be like oh he did
this and like
nobody ever saw it and to me i was like
this is groundbreaking what do you mean
like this look at the look the elegant
code that i wrote
nobody cares yeah it's like i'm i just
came to terms with the fact that like
most of the things that i'm doing are
just completely irrelevant in the grand
scheme of things and that's okay the way
i'm thinking is i'm optimizing for
serendipity this is one of those things
that i
to me is much more important than kind
of the success or failure of the project
because
most connections that i made in life
came from these like serendipitous like
me knowing you
came from one of those serendipitous
projects where i was like what if start
a podcast so what right it's like if i
started the podcast from the very first
day i'm like how do i monetize it how do
i make it a business none of this would
have happened
and a lot of people over optimize for
these things like oh i'm gonna start
this business it's gonna be this massive
success and it's
maybe
or maybe not or maybe it's going to fail
catastrophically and as long as it
doesn't harm anyone else like who cares
yeah that's so true i love that you're
optimizing for serendipity like that to
me is like so like the way that you put
it just like nothing really matters is
like both kind of just like sad but it's
also so zen in my opinion because i
think a lot about just like you know
like even the earth is just but a tiny
blip of existence in the whole universe
and if you think about the amount of
time that the earth has been around then
like we are literally just like specks
of dust in the whole grand scheme and so
if you think about that it's just like
what really is the worst that could
happen like be open to the opportunity
like the big bang and a lot of like
stuff
science things are also all
serendipitous like the fact that human
beings have come this far
complete chance like the
0.000000 however any zeros
percent that we're still alive and
adapting is chance so like optimizing
for as many chance encounters as
possible like that makes so much sense
to me it's one of those things where
there's things that matter there there's
things that 100 matter right like your
relationship with your spouse that
matters that you cannot just leave it
yeah let it let it be whatever you got i
have a product no the worst that could
happen
yeah that that's a priority your
relationship with your family that is
that matters the analogy that i use in
those things is something that one of
again one of my mentors kind of taught
me is like imagine you're juggling a
bunch of
balls
some of them are made of glass and
others are rubber which ones you're
going to drop
right like there are certain things
where you're just like a lot of the
projects that i juggle they're rubber
like if it fails all right whatever i'll
do another project but there's other
things in life that i actually care
deeply about that i know that i cannot
let those things fail so like one of the
other things that i found on the
internet
on your website not really hard to find
uh is the whole like how i work part of
your website which i thought was so
amazing it was just like this is this is
the manual like this is how you work
with den this is how you talk to him
this is how you collaborate with them
and really on it are just like a bunch
of your values about like what you bring
to the workplace how you expect other
people to like interact with you and
what others can expect from you and the
thing that i got from that so much was
like dude this guy is so introspective
and so just like you know in writing
this and like also thinking about like
what are your rubber balls versus your
glass balls would you consider yourself
as like a very introspective person and
has that always been the case so that
document actually i got inspired by
isaac hepworth shout out isaac uh he was
one of my colleagues he had plenty of
experience with twitter and google and
he had his own document working with
isaac and i saw that and i was like i
will steal that idea myself
and so i put together the how i work and
it's been a tremendously helpful
especially when you join a new team you
start working with a new group of people
in any project
you
start going into like a little bit blind
into it because you're like i have no
idea who any of these people are i do
not know what they like what they don't
like what they appreciate
they don't appreciate how they want to
get credit right and it's kind of a
puzzle where a lot of people took this
mentality of like i will spend you know
six months working with them until i
figure it out but then it's like what if
you just had a personal readme and this
is not one of those things where you
know it's like
force everybody to read this doc before
you talk to me like absolutely not no
this is more of like hey if you're
curious why i'm not answering emails
after like 5 p.m
this is a doc right i don't expect you
to answer my emails either
just clears out that kind of confusion
very early on we're like all right i
know how dan works and what he cares
about and hopefully i know how you work
as well and that creates that more
productive relationship where we're just
not guessing things about each other
right it's not one of those things where
like oh well i offended this person
because i emailed them in the morning
and they never respond because they
never respond in the morning because
they have a family and that's okay and
you know to your question of
introspective i think i am most of the
time i like to kind of think back and
think okay what could i've done
differently
what are the areas where maybe i'm not
growing as much as i want to and what
can i do about it like i like to think
about those things as a way to kind of
ground myself is the best way to put it
to say okay you know what nobody's
perfect there is always room for growth
always no matter what you do no matter
how expert you are at something or how
good you are at building things or
communicating there's always room to be
better and i try to ask myself those
questions fairly regularly say okay even
like the how i work document is it's an
ever evolving document like what is
there now it's probably not what's gonna
be there in a month we we assume that
people are static they're not people
evolve you're what you're thinking about
me right now is gonna be drastically
different from probably what you're
gonna think about and say six months
right like a lot of these things they
they evolve and that's okay and somehow
we've put this kind of constraint of
like people are always the same no
they're not i remember one of the
earliest lessons that like someone
taught me i think it was like my first
manager when i started working was just
like literally the only constant in work
in coding in life is change so get
really good at getting used to that and
at first i was just like well yeah duh
like things are changing all the time
but it's like a totally different thing
to like really think about that in
relation to like who you are and how you
change as a person how you perceive
other people and how others change
around you and accepting that change
like that takes so much work and i feel
like i've only recently in the last like
three years like really understood what
he meant i think it's one of those like
i got sage words of advice from an older
person a while ago and now i finally get
what it means
yes and it's it's one of those things
that it takes some time to get
comfortable with i i know for myself it
took me forever to just say you know
what that's okay like do do i care that
this changes can i do anything about it
no why worry then
yeah it's like the really like i think
about like in hard times a lot of what
people say is like the only way out is
through
which really means that you have to face
it head on you have to accept it for
what it is and have it become a part of
your life and then you can get through
it but if you keep like it's like this
like weird like game of tag where if you
try to like get around it it's never
gonna let you
uh and so like accepting it and going
through the change is like the most
productive i guess whatever productive
might mean in this case
right exactly because you're you're spot
on with your description the only way
out is through our life is linear right
like it's it's going day by day by day
by day your decisions accrue but it's
it's moving forward whether you want it
or not so it's up to you of how you
treat that right like are you gonna look
back and say okay what can i do
differently or you're gonna say never
changing this is the path right you know
i think one of them is more productive
than the other
yeah for sure yeah
great well we're coming to the end of
the show
and i want to just kind of like leave
the show on like a nice actionable note
for our listeners and watchers so for
anyone looking for their own path
through life because i know you've
you've thought about this a lot your
whole podcast is around this what advice
do you have for folks i'm always
hesitant with advice a little bit
because everyone's situation is
different right so like me telling you
like follow your dreams
i'd say two things that are very
general but i have not heard many people
talk about it one
incremental progress is underrated
little things done daily compound to big
things all of us think that we're gonna
be celebrities overnight i built this
app why is it not viral you will not get
to a viral app right away or maybe you
will most of the time it takes decade to
become an overnight success right like
it's true because for a lot of the
things that i've noticed that i've done
like again for years nobody paid
attention up until one moment it's like
wait what
right that's one the second one i'd say
optimize for options a lot of people try
to optimize i'm gonna optimize for the
most financial success or the most
career growth optimize for the ability
to make changes when you want to make
changes because
options and the ability to say you know
what i'm going to do something else
is immensely powerful that a lot of
people miss and they think they lose
track of the fact that it's like it's
about money or it's about career it's
about options
optimize
for options in your life
that's my advice
i love that a lot dense fortune cookies
of advice that may or may not apply to
you but you take whatever meaning you
want because that's what the show is
about right right all right awesome i'm
stealing that see it says i'm gonna open
a page on my blog that says dense
fortune cookie advice
you know some people really believe
fortune cookies and some people are just
like it's a fortune cookie so and you
know how some of them are oddly accurate
where sometimes you're just like oh i
have like uh i don't know tomorrow i
have a job interview and you got a
fortune cookie and it says like you will
get the job and you're like what do you
know that i don't know
who wrote this who's watching me why are
they doing this exactly thank you so
much jen for being on the show this has
been incredibly fun make sure to check
out dan and all of his work his website
the work item podcast which is linked in
the description box down below and thank
you for having me this has been a
delight uh i'm always inspired by your
work and to folks listening and watching
my eco came super prepared for the show
and got notes and everything and i just
it was easy for me because i came in and
i was like oh cool yeah i can answer a
bunch of questions so this this has been
phenomenal thank you for having me thank
you we had a bit of a technical hiccup
too which you just been lovely i
couldn't have asked for it like a better
first like re-doing of mucho's corner
and this has just been so fun so i'm
gonna i'm definitely gonna have to have
you back on again this is lovely always
happy too thank you all right
you can also listen to this episode of
mooco's corner through the podcast
mooco's corner through your favorite
podcasting app thank you everyone so
much for watching and listening and i'll
see you next time bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you